sur le lac au mali dans les cantons de
l'est une équipe de biologistes de
plongeurs et bénévoles tentent de sauver
le lac de le protéger contre le
myriophylle à hippies si rien n'est fait
cette plante zombies risque carrément de
faire mourir le plan d'eau son fonds
n'investit pas temps et argent à chaque
été la mairie fait va prendre le dessus
et puis les nos lacs au québec seront
peut être rien
ça a même un impact sur la valeur des
propriétaires allant tôt donc cette
importance est pas seulement un enjeu
environnemental mais sans danger connaît
mais aussi le myriophylle à épi est
apparu dans le saint-laurent il ya 40
ans l'algue s'est depuis propagée dans
au moins 188 lacs québécois c'est 95%
chez nous si vous et moi qui
transportant malheureusement vers le
meilleur fils dans les lacs alors le
truc c'est de s'arranger depuis jamais
prendre son embarcation et dans les
dalles et dans un nouveau l'accent avoir
nettoyer manuellement ou avec un jet
d'eau son embarcation quelle qu'elle
soit pédalo kayak side où on l'appelle
blandine by car dès qu'on tente de la
coupe et elles se multiplient
l'algue est presque impossible à
éliminer tel qu'un bateau moteur ou une
embarcation qui parle de milliers de
petits fragments qui refont des bébés
c'est une plante qui est tellement
envahissante les fait disparaître toutes
les espèces indigènes de plantes colo
premier problème le deuxième c'est que
c'est une densité absolument incroyable
de biomasse
on calcule que ça peut dans un mètre
carré être multi alors qu'en haut à
l'automne comme les feuilles à l'automne
ça se déposent ça fait une quantité de
sédiments organique de matières
organiques beaucoup plus grande que
l'arbre et qui dit matières organiques
dit on commença bouffée d'oxygène
hélas il commença bouffée d'oxygène
dissous dans un lac
tu es trop fille tu vieilli
prématurément temps là que beaucoup ont
fait là toi aussi on a trois on disait
qu'il pouvait contaminer beaucoup à
l'équipe de biologistes de la
coopérative rappelle travail depuis cinq
ans avec les résidents du lac au mal et
je vous donne un avis l'association ici
la municipalité en cinq ans et on y sent
métal à séverin concots abaissement
cool une toile de jute l'équipe va
étouffer
l'algue au fond de l'eau sur le coût
complet parce que si tu allais ses côtés
il veut recoloniser
nous on tient notre lac le puits demain
14 on pose des toiles des toiles de jute
au fond du lac
vous couvrez les arts viennent des
profils on était un des premiers la cale
faire et à chaque année on en a posé et
c'est important pour nous de continuer
quelques kilomètres du lac au mali
les résidents du lac d'argent doivent
eux aussi se résoudre à déployer des
toiles les gens ne peuvent plus se
baigner dans ces herbiers l'eau et qu'il
est difficilement une circuler avec une
embarcation et kayak ou une chaloupe
ça devient difficile et c'est dangereux
de le faire à ce moment là parce qu'on
répond encore davantage on propage la
plante si on a le malheur de couper les
tiges
cette technique permet de maîtriser en
partie la présence de l'algue mais pour
jean claude thibault il est impératif
d'agir pour limiter la propagation du
myriophylle si le bon moment
d'intervenir
je savais que ça vienne thématique là
c'est vraiment le temps d'intervenir
pour réussir une poêle propager il faut
que je la vole à vocation ça viendrait
des problèmes ici vincent maisonneuve
radio-canada austen